In this first
recitation, we will
try to understand various
nutritional facts about food,
while getting more practice
using R. Good nutrition
is an important part of
leading a healthy lifestyle.
Malnutrition can
result in obesity,
which has been rising
at an alarming rate.
In the US for instance,
while all states in 1990
had less than 14% obesity,
figures started increasing.
And by 2000, half of the
country has more than 20%
of its population obese.
The trend continues.
And in 2010, all states
have at least more than 20%
of their population obese.
Many states across the country
reached an alarming situation.
More than 35% of American
adults are obese.
The trends Worldwide
are no different.
Obesity has nearly
doubled across the globe.
Obesity is one of today's
blatantly visible public health
problems, and
increases people's risk
to heart disease,
stroke, and diabetes.
In fact 65% of the
world's population
lives in countries
where obesity kills
more people than underweight.
So good nutrition is essential
for an overall healthy
lifestyle and promoting it now
is more important than ever.
We have access to hundreds
of nutrition and weight loss
applications, and around 15%
of adults with cell phones
use health applications
on their devices.
These apps are mostly powered
by the United States Department
of Agricultural, or
USDA, food database.
The United States
Department of Agricultural
distributes
nutritional information
of over 7,000 food
items including
amount of calories,
carbs, protein, fat,
and sodium, among
other nutrients.
It is exactly this
data that we will
be analyzing in this recitation.
In the next video, we will
read in the USDA data set in R
and get more familiar
with its content.